Jesse had a you know a big love for
running and that's the that's the
biggest most important thing to him I
definitely had to go into all the
training needed to play fastest man on
the planet he was not one to boast about
what he did but he did believe in
sustained and physical good physical
condition and at the peak of his career
he trained constantly and he firmly
believed you set goals for yourself and
you strive to believe in yourself you
want to do it again yeah I think I was
running the hundred in just over 12
seconds something like that so I got
much better while making this film I
gotta say that I will say you can run
what I want to know is can you win his
coach Larry's techniques were innovative
for the time and it helped correct his
posture it you know shaved off you know
0.2 seconds here 0.3 seconds there it
was a god-given talent and he was helped
to develop that talent and to hone it to
a fine point but they had something to
work with do you want to win a gold
medal stuff well I'm doing in Berlin he
won a number of gold medals in Berlin in
front of Hitler the Buckeye bullet took
gold medals in three events
Hitler was too snob Owens as you get
almost all of the American winners he
did not go to meet Hitler or to shake
Hitler's hand he went to run and that's
what he did and he proved to the world
that he could come home with four gold
medals he just did what he did based on
the strength or a love for his sport now
he's just showing off he was certainly a
man who wanted change having lived
through what he lives through I've got
people looking at me funny
then with your white Larry you don't
have to I think it's certainly important
that you know people are are having this
sort of a discussion you know anytime we
have the discussion it always you know
it's always a healthy thing
he didn't just change the sport jesse
changed the world with that mentality
for those 10 seconds to up completely
free when I look at a guy like him who
was able to look over the Berlin Germany
and accomplish what he did you think
Jesse Owens could do it I could do it